le style cru de virginie despentes son
dernier ouvrage les jolies choses et
dans la lignée de son premier livre
baise moi une jeune femme à l'écriture
choc et qui ne mâche pas ses mots
dominique poncet et may hamm état où ils
ont rencontré vos livres sont très crus
est quand même belle lui pratiques sont
vachement cru aussi je pensais pas que
moi qui puis j'aime bien j'aime bien les
trucs un peu vif quoi on peut cache
jamais allé de son cru avant de devenir
écrivain avec un livre qui ébranla le
landerneau littéraire et qui
s'intitulait baise moi
elle fut zonards punk et prostituée ce
qui advient chez virginie despentes 29
ans aujourd'hui c'est qu'elle ne change
pas son style en forme d'uppercut et ses
histoires aussi salée qu'haletante ce
sont ses potes acdi stroy qui les lui
inspire son troisième roman les jolies
choses nous plonge dans le monde frelaté
du showbiz
au début quand j'ai compris que j'allais
devenir écrivain je trouve ça pas très
glamour quoi servons des suffrages au
mieux une journée m d'autres trucs
d'amour quoi l'on fait sa chanteuse ou
un truc plus classe quoi je suis pour
faire autre chose elle est écrivain jeu
max est un petit peu car on s'en sert
encore mais c'est pas le meilleur milieu
pro tools et quand on y rigole comme des
enfants assassinés en fait c'est au
final qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui vous
fascine dans ce milieu on va dire
interlope
parce que je sais pas très bien les
qualifier ce milieu des deux nuits d
qu'est ce qui vous fascine dans ce
milieu là bas chez obligeant les gens
comme on voit avec quand même c'est une
liberté comme plus pour que quand les
apprenants melliti arrachement plus de
code corps puis elle notion de soin au
fait comme ci comme ça avant la classe
représenter plein de trucs leur place
c'est vachement plus chacun fait comme
il veut quand même bien que c'est plus
court plus vivants mage noir
comment vous bien ce style de rue et il
s'est vraiment en deux mouvements il ya
une première réflexion qui est vraiment
à toute vitesse quoi et puis l erreur
travaux motion je crois bien vachement
sens que j'ai férocement ça fait comme
une prise de son très crus et puis
ensuite vraiment un travail en studio
pour comparer à de la musique quoi est
ce qui vous énerve ou plus bien des
trucs que sur moi - voilà avec notamment
ce moment avec aussi repêché un bas-côté
tout le monde fait les mêmes trucs pour
les montres localement souvent je me
retrouvais des gens parlent cependant le
strictement rien à [ __ ] bouquin est
sûrement les trucs et les interactions
qu'elle s'intéresse à céline
intéresseront et voilà c'est dit trois
petits tours et elle s'en va rebelle on
l'espère à tout jamais le mythe